guys this is your final week to get some
trash taste drip what are you waiting
for why are you watching this video
click the link in the description right
now bye bye bye subliminal mastering buy
the trash taste much you're gonna regret
it if you don't get it right now you
have exactly one week left seven whole
days and after that you will never see
these ever again don't complain to us we
gave you a fair warning Link in the
description right now we got t-shirts we
got the sweater Everything is Beautiful
Everything is delicious get your hands
on it right now Link in the description
you [ __ ] loved me you [ __ ] War
mate
welcome back to this episode of trash
taste I'm Connor and I'm here again once
again [ __ ] say it again once again again
once again with the boys gun Joe I
really [ __ ] that up so that's wow
trash day special it's been a while
since you've hosted yeah oh yeah it
feels like it even though we've filmed a
bunch of episodes uh we've been away
yeah yeah well the last one you hosted
was Felix yeah that was yeah which was
like three months ago for us you guys
right that was that was really really
soon right right guys how you guys been
what you been up to
I was thinking about it I'm like that's
a really [ __ ] good question so what
have I done this week other than just
play Pokemon
I've been touching grass you've been
touching some virtual games I've been
touching some virtual five frames per
second grass yeah we all know we've
already established you don't see frames
you don't you can't sell this between
six times that's why that's why you like
them that's why people like people are
like oh the switch has performance
issues and this game runs like [ __ ] I'm
like what are you talking about
exactly the same oh my God the fact that
I've seen clips and so much [ __ ] I'm
like how could you not tell the
difference this is okay so yeah I mean
there was like there was rumors going
around being like Oh if you bought the
physical copy then it runs a million
times more worse and it's a million
times more glitchy than the digital
version yeah so maybe that's why because
like mine was like I had a couple of
like because you know yeah I mean I had
a couple of like frame drops and [ __ ]
like that and a lot of parts that were
like
struggling to load
um but I want having like a huge crashes
like some people would so maybe there's
some truth to that matter but um sorry I
think they sold 10 million copies in the
first three days yeah are you serious
yeah it's very successful it was a very
highly anticipated series
um yeah I mean I I just finished it
yesterday actually I know nothing about
this because I don't really follow the
gaming sphere especially Pokemon yeah so
is this like a new Mainline game or is
this it's the ninth generation okay and
is it like 2D 3D 3D
um so so it's it's kind of like Legends
Arceus if you saw anything about that
except this time it's actually open
world unlike Arceus that was is an open
zone game and I'm like oh is that a
Sonic game it's like areas that are open
but then I think that's been a lot of
other games and we need a term for it we
were just like that's level yeah it's
like uh it's like Mario Odyssey right
where it's like you it's like once you
open up the world then you have free
range on the entire world and you can do
whatever the [ __ ] you want in that area
but in in order to open up the next Zone
you have to progress in the story right
right whereas this one is the actual
first proper open world where like the
entire map is actually open for you okay
and like the only like roadblocks of
like traversing through the world is
like you know you got to get your
Pokemon like surf so you can go on the
ocean or something like that but other
than that like places you can walk it's
fully open okay okay as somebody who's
played a [ __ ] ton of Pokemon and I don't
really feel that interested to play this
new one is there any reason I should
play the new one is there anything new
um
[Music]
not for reasons you will care about
because let me guess story yeah
story and music are probably the best in
any Pokemon game two things
let me tell you about the story and the
music it's it's incredible because the
gameplay changed at all okay so the game
okay so the gameplay Loop okay did you
play Arceus at all I did okay did you
like the gameplay Looper bosses yeah
okay then it's it's essentially the same
all the Pokemon are running around uh in
the open World um of course it's like I
would say Arceus was miraculously
somehow Less buggier in that sense
because there are moments where like
Pokemon will suddenly appear and then
you approach him and then they just
straight up disappear and so there's
like a great game I mean it's great to
stream because it's hilarious yeah
because the game is just so glitchy and
broken but like other than that like the
gameplay loop I would say is really good
and I I don't know this is like the big
argument when it comes to like every new
generation of Pokemon being like have
Pokemon designs gotten lazier or have
they gotten better that's like a
never-ending [ __ ] argument right like
more like you know from the brief like
pictures I saw of the new Pokemon they
look more like Digimon than Pokemon a
lot of people have said that they they
very much look like whoa okay I will say
though I think this is probably the one
generation where I think all three
starter Pokemon are just as popular as
one another okay because like you know
how like in like gen 1 for example it's
like clearly like you know uh
charmanderal Squirtle were like the top
two contenders it's like Bulbasaur I
sleep yeah you know and it was like
there's oh there was always one starter
where it's like I sleep or there was a
clear winner I feel in this generation
I've seen like almost an equal
dispersion of all three starters because
I think like all three of the designs
are really solid and like just again
like the gameplay kind of really cult
not doesn't really matter really like
what kind of study you pick at the end
of the day because it is an opal world
and you can go in any direction I want
them to make starters that aren't water
fire or grass
tell her they should do that just like
is it because of the is it because of
the the three colors that are
aesthetically pleasing is that why yeah
and why do we stick to it well I guess
it's also because of the OG like
triangle right yeah like you know what
is stronger than the other you know kind
of thing I guess so I feel like it could
be more exciting to yeah I agree to mix
up you know just I agree because they
all get two types anyway now yeah so
it's like all right well why don't we
just do all right well if it gets fire
later on or some [ __ ] yeah but I'm sure
you can like Traverse through the game
without using your starter at all yeah I
mean you normally can Pokemon's easy
enough now where you have to have one IQ
to yeah like it's it's I it's really
hard to [ __ ] up it is it is I mean is it
is it worth getting back into Pokemon
nowadays because
where did you stop I I stopped uh
Pokemon Ruby that's which yes I know
wrong I know I mean you did you did it
you did play Peak Pokemon in my yeah
yeah yeah because I I played red and
blue I played gold and silver then I
played Ruby and I was like okay I think
I'm done and that's fair I think and
it's been like how many decades now yeah
formula hasn't changed and it's gotten
easier yeah so I think the reason why
Pokemon has had a lot of longevity
amongst older people is that you add the
nuzlocker the challenges yeah yeah you
add a spin to it that makes it
interesting for yourself yeah because
because the way I see the Pokemon
franchise in my mind it's it's kind of
like the same way you know isekai is for
anime where it's it's it's iterations of
the same idea
well okay if you like it I don't know I
did more by that they're both pretty I
was gonna say something like it's a lot
like Game of Thrones where it's like if
you're like if you're like six seven
no in the sense of like how the fan base
Works where it's like okay if you're
already six or seven seasons in you
might as well just [ __ ] finish the
rest at that point
what are you talking about
are you talking about Joe
um what I mean is if you're it's it's a
lot like any long-form TV series where
it's got multiple Series right or
multiple Seasons we're like okay you
enjoyed the first couple of ones okay
maybe the third or fourth one slightly
stunned to go downhill but you're
already committed at this point you
might as well I don't agree with this I
feel like I haven't enjoyed every
Pokemon game some of the Pokemon games
in in my opinion have been quite [ __ ]
like sun and moon was we're pretty mid
in my opinion sword and shield was dog
[ __ ] it wasn't dog [ __ ] it wasn't I
hated that it was oh I hated it
um X and Y was like yeah it was okay as
well um I can't remember a single
Pokemon from sword and shield except for
like the the two characters the sword on
the shield yeah
if you if you tell me to name any
Pokemon from that game I'm like
I'm the same though with like X and Y or
like sun and moon I'm like after that
point for me it's like after Gen 4 and
the recent one that I just played I
don't really remember it I didn't play X
and Y or son of shields that's why I
don't but I I don't I played the whole
game I don't remember any but also I I
wouldn't say it's like the Game of
Thrones analogy I'd say it's more like
well it's it's independent Series right
so there's no ongoing no it's okay okay
is not the same isakai Series right it's
not like we've done this is one guy in
the same world as a smartphone and
there's a different story with a
different uh the cast of characters oh
it's it's like your take it's like
iterations of the same kind of formula
it's it's kind of like it's like no
because that would be like no
yes
is there like an ongoing story or
something no but but like Doctor Who is
also in in the sense
but Pokemon also has callbacks as well
like there are a lot of callbacks in the
newer Generations where you wouldn't
really really understand it I think
especially in terms of like the war
which is in the same with Doctor Who
right where it's like you could just
like go straight into season 10 which is
everyone who's the best doctor who have
you I've watched five to eleven who
doesn't well it kind of does separate
but then they do have they do have call
backs and mentions yeah I'm nervous I've
never seen the first couple of messes
like in terms of the Doctor Who I've
never seen like the first four seasons
to talk to her no no but I still enjoyed
all the seasons I watched because they
don't heavily depend on the callbacks
like it's it's kind of like if you want
to fully hunt it's like a trash taste
episode you know you don't have to watch
the one before yeah but it's the same
thing no I mean I mean Doctor Who has
always had like one goal which is you
know for for the dogs which you know
find Gallifrey you know find find other
time Lords and stuff like that that's
there's always been like one Central
goal and then you've had like story arcs
that have like come and gone with
different characters and everything but
the core idea of the show as always
remains kind of the same Pokemon's
exactly the same what's the end goal to
be the very best there are a couple of
Side characters that have their own
storylines before but at the end of the
day you're there to [ __ ] beat the
Elite Four and be the champion yeah
there's no need to play any Pokemon game
prior time yeah yeah I get that even I
think like black and white black and
white two I don't even think their
stories aren't necessarily like yeah
what I was trying to say is I got like
the reason I stopped playing was just
because I got kind of tired of the
formula and then I was just like is
there anything what I was trying to ask
is that is there anything new to like
bring me back yes so aside from Arceus
which actually looks interesting yeah
well Arceus is not even a Mainline game
yeah like in terms of violent Scarlet
the new one yeah what what I thought was
really really cool was like the the open
wall thing is of course one thing but
also now there are three branching
storylines that you can choose to do oh
okay and it's pretty cool and it's and
so it's like one of the story lines is
the BTA gyms beat the Elite Four become
the champion the standard one yeah and
and then there are two other storylines
that you can do that follow two separate
characters and then well I mean at the
end of the day
in order to get to like the final end
end you have to do all three story lines
anyway but you can do this storyline in
any order you want that's cool so you
can choose to be like I'm just gonna
[ __ ] Elite Four and become a champion
and then start this next one or what I
did was I did all three simultaneously
okay and so it's like okay so I just
defeated uh the fifth gym uh you know
instead of going to the sixth gym I'm
just gonna go do this next part of this
story right and so it's kind of like a
pick you're an adventure type of style
and that works really well in like the
open world setting yeah so now it
becomes like this fresh new thing that
you can do it's not just like uh I need
to make the best team and you know
become the best people criticizing the
the visuals of the game that they don't
look as good as up to par as other
Nintendo switch games okay so one thing
I I don't know if this is a hot take but
I personally don't have a problem with
like the way that the game looks because
I mean if you think about it that just
kind of how it works in the style of
Pokemon right like I can't imagine a
Pokemon game that has the graphics of
like a breath of the Wild Well I think
it's that I think they're just saying I
think a lot of criticism was was levied
at them because of like you know the
sceneries look really [ __ ] boring oh
yeah they do I've seen a lot of the
screenshots of the game like wow this
this looks so visually boring it is yeah
all the backgrounds and all the textures
look really bad but I think as well uh
you know unlike say like because you
know the one game a lot of people use to
compare his breath of the wild right
being like Oh breath of the wild had
like so much [ __ ] going on and you know
like the environment was actually like
interactive and really cool but like the
whole point of breath of the wild is to
interact with your surroundings whereas
in the Pokemon games it's not to
interact with the surroundings it's
interact with the Pokemon but I
understand that I I would be like wow
this Pokemon in this natural habitat on
this one one by one PNG texture like I'd
be like well you know yeah no could they
have done better absolutely yeah yeah
like so they're getting they're getting
closer to like indie horror devs really
like we're just like we're just we're
just making one big texture game Frank
is doing this really cool thing where
they're bringing back the PS2
one thing that odds that has always
confused me about I guess like the
success of Pokemon like Mainline Pokemon
games right is that would you say that
there has been a Pokemon game within
like the last few years that you would
say is like an absolute must play kind
of like the kind of like killer app that
you'd see like breath of the wild or
like I like I've really really highly
acclaimed game because really a lot of
people's favorite game is black and
white too A lot of people love that one
but again but the Nintendo DS era is all
I mean they're very my new changes each
one and improvements also also I think a
lot of Pokemon fans favorite to black
and white twos because it has one of the
best stories yeah
um but if you don't give a [ __ ] about
the story Pokemon games which a lot of
Pokemon players don't then it's like
it's there's not really there's no game
you have to play I think it's Pokemon is
just a juggernaut of advertising yeah oh
yeah yeah and also it's easy like you as
a parent you don't have to think about
buying your Pokemon yeah as you as the
parent know what Pokemon is it's like
Mario you don't have to there isn't like
a must play Mario game there are some
[ __ ] classes
are you saying that through Nostalgia
goggles or is that you saying that
through like Odyssey Still Remains as
like one of the best switch games and
like what like I I think it was like my
game of the year like the year was
released it was like a [ __ ]
incredible games they looked like Zelda
as well
completely revolutionized the gaming uh
the open world the open world genre
after it got released so there have been
like there have been like big IPS that
have that have had killer apps but for
me it always confused me up about
Pokemon is that it sells like [ __ ]
hot cakes it's it it breaks every kind
of record imaginable and then I look at
the game reviews and then every every
time a new game comes out it's like yes
it's all right it's good it's because
it's because I feel Pokemon generally
are appealing to two types of player
bases the children and the old school
Pokemon fans right right they're not
trying to get like this new adult fan
base the who has never played Pokemon
before because they know there's no
Pokemon game that they can make that
will be like like a 20 year old you know
kid yeah who's never played a Pokemon
game would be like yeah you know what I
should give that game a go you know
they're not going to do that it's like
water everyone drinks water whereas the
wild is like the most Exquisite wine oh
[ __ ] I gotta be 21. I gotta have some
money oh man I gotta be in wine like if
you like this
it's the best thing ever if you have
that that you know you want to get into
it but Pokemon is so so basic Fiji Water
again
anyone can drink it anyone even drinks
that anyone likes it yeah everyone's
good everyone's gonna drink it but no
one's gonna be you know ejaculating over
a bottle of Fiji Water you know they're
just gonna be like yeah it quench my
thirst yeah I'm satisfied I I yeah I
don't know personally I'm just like kind
of over Pokemon I'm like I kind of enjoy
it when there's a Nuzlocke or something
fun to do no and I and that's the thing
I totally get that which is why I always
find it frustrating when these [ __ ]
Pokemon fans are like no no I swear this
is the new this is the generation that
everyone has to play I'm like no they
don't because at the end of the day it's
a [ __ ] children's game they want to
say that I thought Pokemon fans hate
everything they do oh okay but Pokemon
fans are the type of [ __ ] who
will be like you know first week of
violent scholar coming up being like
this game looks like [ __ ] and then a
week later they'll be like all right
I'll give it a go
yeah it's like I'll complain about
everything yeah it's funny you're
talking about this because I've just
been I just finished drinking the finest
wine
the the finest top tier wine because I
think I might have breath of all the
blind yeah yeah I mean I think I might
have found like a game that's come into
like my new top 10 games of all time uh
because I just finished playing God of
War the new God of War oh and that is
it's it's like incredible yeah every
every sense of the words and I'm just
like [ __ ]
it's I I finished it like two days ago
and it's been a while since I've just
finished a video game I'm like I don't
know what to do with my life now what
like I just feel an emptiness and I just
looked at like other because after
playing God of War I was just like I
wanted to play some other games and I
just looked through my game list and I
was like none of this is doing anything
for me I don't know one of this excites
me no no this excites me anymore how how
on Earth do I become a gamer again you
have the post not Clarity of games yeah
yeah I don't know what to do anymore I
don't know what you should do play
Scotland
no that would that would just make it
worse because then I would just start
playing it I'm like this is this isn't
good no dude because you you'll you'll
understand the story is really good how
long is it and the music's really good
as long as the PS5 been out for
uh years two years two years two years
because it came out really I thought it
was like two and a half yeah I think
it's like two and a half years yeah I
just realized I'm like I I have I've had
a PS5 and I've only gamed on it like one
time bro God of War I I think you would
really like it do I need to play the
previous God yes you do see that's the
problem is that I gotta go play the old
one I'm like oh have you played any of
them it's it's all like the second one
basically
um you have you played stuff like the
last of us or Uncharted or stuff like
that because it's kind of like in the
same kind of vein where it is like kind
of like a cinematic experience
yeah it looks really good yeah just I
don't know if I have the heart of me to
go and play the old one just to play the
new one well actually like the old one I
think the old one is [ __ ] fan is a
fantastic game by itself as well
um and by itself it's still a fantastic
game you're not losing anything by
playing the old one yeah the only thing
um like the old one Builds on these like
gameplay ideas and stuff like that and
one of the biggest criticisms of the old
one was there was just not enough
variation in one like the boss battles
and two enemy types
um and like and like kind of like the
gameplay itself and that's just because
with the first one they were completely
rebuilding the franchise
so I actually really liked you know the
new like when they introduced like new
gameplay it's a bit slower a bit heavier
but
I think that's the perfect introduction
to this new game which takes all of the
ideas from this old game and then Builds
on everything basically so so when
playing the old one you'll get like the
freshness of like oh this feels good
this feels good and then just as it's
about to get boring then then you finish
the game and then you can go to the new
one where all these new ideas start
getting iterated and added on and right
yeah I think it's like the perfect
Journey as well from playing like the
first one to the second one because one
the story is amazing in both games
um and I'm surprised that they I'm
surprised they only did two games
because I expected it to be a Trilogy of
sorts but no it's it's after two games
the entire story arc is ended now so
it's the entire story arc of uh of the
Nordic gods or this this Nordic Arc per
se and yeah honestly one of the best
video game stories I've uh ever
experienced damn now you got to finish
Alden ring so you can find out what game
of the year is this year yeah
okay here's the thing I even and even if
I finish Elder ring I don't think it
could beat God of War for me because you
know you know me story story important
aspects of course there's another story
in Elden
tell me the story you know them again
there's a ring of some kind I guess
because okay here's here here's the
thing uh what playing God of War made me
realize and uh this is do you want to
play a movie huh is you wanna no no no
no no no no no no I would play depth
training but that's actually the
opposite actually the opposite it made
me realize okay I actually do really
care about gameplay
but but like okay so let me let me break
this down right so there are some very
much Elden ring Souls like bosses in God
of War that are really really
challenging
um but you really have to it's like a
side quest right so it's not the main
quest story it's optional boss so the
hardest bosses in the game have nothing
to do with the mainline story right
that's good and and basically God of War
was one of those games that I enjoyed so
much that I wanted to complete like I
100 in the game which is only the second
game in my life that I've ever 100 which
just shows how much what's your first
one huh my first one is uh tails game
tails of symphony what the [ __ ] wait
you've never before that you'd never 100
of the game no I know what okay I'll
tell you I'll I'll get to that I'll get
to that because what happened is I would
complete the story and I'm like okay
done well I don't need to play this game
anymore right you never thought wow this
game is fun I wonder if I should just do
the rest of the game no no that's that's
my point right because what I really
liked about God of War is that you can
do like one one thing side quest side
quests are [ __ ] incredible they
have as much impact into your emotions
and the story I feel like as much as
Mainline quest lines right that's that's
one thing that makes a really really
special game that's why everyone loves
The Witcher 3 and stuff like that God of
War has the same kind of philosophy
where you can do the mainline Quest but
the side quests are in my opinion just
as high quality as the mainline quests
so I wanted to do every single aspect of
this game
um and so by being really really high
quality it's a it tricked me into doing
the optional bosses right because
otherwise I would have no interest in
doing these optional hard bosses uh
because I'm like I'm here for the story
but because the quality of the story was
so high it tricked me into wanting to do
the optional bosses and in that process
I really really [ __ ] enjoyed my time
just challenging myself and just you
know doing like the whole Souls kind of
repeat Die Repeat die and after about 20
[ __ ] tries you finally to get that
Boston like that feels [ __ ] great
yeah I know I wouldn't have done that if
there wasn't a storyline to play through
right it's it's like I with gameplay in
order for me like you wanted to be
immersed in rather than just tacked on
at the end I need I need to know that
there's a payoff at the end right other
than just an intrinsic well isn't the
payoff the [ __ ] away so you just can't
you're like you play a game and you're
the only point of playing the game is so
that you know the ending's good yeah so
I know that so I know that I get
rewarded with something most of the time
isn't the payoff the fact that you 100
completed the game you like fighting
games right
I mean I mean I I do not like play a
game you're like oh this mechanics are
fun I want to keep playing this you're
like you're like I've got I hope this is
paying off soon I I'll find out I think
fighting games are different because I
think competitive games are different
because you get the satisfaction of
beating a human opponent right whereas
whereas in you know Souls like games
I've really really enjoyed the bosses
but there's even though I feel really
really satisfied there's just there's
always this part missing where I want I
want to know I'm working towards
something I want to know I'm working
towards a storyline or you know
self-improvement not a something you're
working towards is that not valuable
that's that's why that's why I could
never really get into competitive games
um well I mean like for like if I when I
played like Alden ring I'm like oh I
really enjoyed the aspect of
understanding the game mechanics and
getting better at doing it yeah I
enjoyed that I enjoyed getting better at
it so you necessarily care about what I
was getting I enjoyed that as well but
it's not the core reason I would ever
play a game okay because I that I I can
appreciate it but it's kind of it's kind
of like you need you need to trick me
into okay getting me to care about it
you're gonna just get better at any kind
of thing that allows me better like it
would be something else there which is
why which is why I'm really I'm really
curious to see how you how you react to
God of War right because I think God of
War is like I've never seen such a
perfect marriage of gameplay and story
that blends so seamlessly God of War got
me to care about gameplay because it's
so seamlessly Blended in with the
combats
it Blended so seamlessly in with the
story that it actually got me to care
about the gameplay so there's a chance
that Conor might actually care about the
story I'm one I'm wondering if he could
do the impossible and get Connor to care
about the story because it got me to
care about the gameplay it got me to 100
in the game I [ __ ] love the gameplay
love the mechanics it got me to learn
like it's it's one of those gameplay
mechanics that's easy to pick up but
really really hard to master when you
get to like some of the really tougher
optional bosses and stuff like that
um and it got me to really care about
that which I would never usually spend
this many hours like learning learning
the mechanics of the gameplay um but I
did it because the story is amazing and
I wanted to grind through the story and
I wanted to experience as much of this
world and as much of these characters
um as I could that um Santa Monica
Studio have written and I've like built
up in this world I wanted to experience
and just spend more time with them and
that's why I wanted to grind through the
gameplay was because it was just such a
pleasure to spend time in this world and
the story I'm wondering if it could get
you to care about the story in the world
building
I heard a story very complicated
um first one is very simple and the
second one I heard was very like
complicated it's I I'm used to jrpg
storylines this is like a simple app
storyline to be like oh what do you mean
you didn't read the full Wikipedia page
before starting this Arc and it's like
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you I'm not
gonna go out and Google [ __ ] yeah just
let me play the game like if I got I
want to watch Connor play 13 cents
the game requires you to like study
outside of the game or read [ __ ] outside
of the game then I think it's failed as
a game oh no like a story it's it's not
in fact I've way preferred the second
game because the story had the story was
a bit more complicated there were a lot
more aspects Connor you forget God's a
fate fan yeah
it's not even it's not even complicated
I don't think it's it's like
I'm just think I'm just thinking because
like the first the first game was about
as simple as you can get okay let me let
me tell you the story of the first game
okay so so Kratos is a dad in this one
he has a wife his wife dies and his wife
says please spread my ashes on the
highest peak on the Realms and the first
game is them going to the highest realm
I've been spreading her ashes and that's
that's the game that's right that's how
yeah I like that yeah that's that's easy
easy second game
um it's about time travel comes in
multiple Dimensions so there's Kratos
blue yeah
Super Saiyan Kratos yeah the second game
is more about well they don't want
Kratos doesn't want to go to war because
he's even though he's the God of War he
doesn't really want to go to war and
then inevitably they find uh he ends up
going to war yeah that's a very
simplified version of the events but
that's basically what happens
they needed to find a reason for
conflict to happen and that's why I
think the second game is a bit more a
bit more like has more moving Parts but
at the end of the day it's compared to
like some other movies or some other
stories I mean I I think the [ __ ] MCU
is more complicated than game uh than
the God of War so it's it's not a
complicated the MCU is not complicated
out of design it's complicated because
they're trying to milk it and then yeah
it's getting out of hand yeah and also
it's [ __ ] yeah like if you can follow
[ __ ] like Game of Thrones or most I mean
most TV shows God of War is not that
complicated at all he can be if you like
go into like the lawn like the World
building and everything like that but in
terms like the the core story it's it's
fine it's fine your monkey brain can
follow along don't worry about it
today's sponsor is Paypal honey the easy
way to save When shopping on your iPhone
or Computer Boys the holidays are coming
up how do you feel about your shopping
experience oh I'm dreading it Joey I'm
dreading it you're telling me you have
to go outside and Shop Joey Japan's open
right now tourists are here well how do
you guys feel about the online shopping
experience but just that promo codes
well thanks to Honey manually searching
for coupon codes thing of the past
Honey's the free shopping tool that
scales the internet for promo codes and
applies the best ones it finds to your
cart I actually tried to get my
Christmas shopping done a little bit
early today and I bought something for
my wife I'm not gonna spoil what it is
but I saved 15 on my Christmas present
guys yeah you can save even more when
you ask honey to keep track of price
drops on your holiday shopping list if
the price drops on anything on your your
list you're instantly get an alert to
let you know and if you don't already
have honey you could be straight up
missing out and by getting it you'll not
only be doing yourself a solid however
you're buying a presents for a solid but
also you'll be helping out the boys as
well so get PayPal honey 4 for free at
joinhoney.com Taste that's Joint
honey.com Trash taste this episode is
sponsored by boxu ho ho ho ho boys the
most wonderful time is upon us crimbus
yes that one and you know what will make
this time even better telling children
Santa isn't real no gingerbread lattes
no the correct answer is sharing's this
month's themed boxing with your friends
and family guys
longtime viewers of the channel will
know what boxu is but we love boxes they
work with family businesses all over
Japan to send you a new theme of goodies
every single month and this month being
the month of December the final month of
this year we have the Hokkaido
Wonderland
we've traveled to Hokkaido a bunch of
times ourselves and even went to the
most northern point of Japan in Hong
Kong which you can watch on the Japan
trash day special and we can assure you
that Hokkaido is a splendid place to
visit Joey what do you got there I got
here a mirukumanju Manju being like a
sweet dumpling and as you know Hokkaido
is known for their Exquisite milk oh yes
oh that's actually really nice what do
you got there guard I have here a white
milk Boucher which is kind of like a
cream cake oh that's big that looks fish
chunky like the bird itself man it's
good very much
every time you get your boxer in the
mail you can feel good knowing that
you're supporting family businesses and
supporting the boys this holiday season
as well so if you want to get your
friends and family members a wonderful
gift this holiday season get them a
boxer box and support the channel use
our code trash taste and the link in the
description down below to save 15 off
your order happy holidays back to the
show what else what have we talked about
recently I I remember did you speak
about House of dragon I watched that
that was really I've started watching
that it's so good yeah it's so so good
what's that it's um
okay is it complicated no it's it's um
uh pre-call but it's sort of connect is
a Game of Thrones but it sort of is sort
of it's like 300 400 years before Game
of Thrones do I have to watch Game of
Thrones no no no no not at all it's
really good and it's got Matt Smith and
he's really getting it Matt Smith is
Great Net he's [ __ ] awesome I love
Matt Smith he's so good I think I'm like
three episodes in right now it's I don't
know how you could watch three episodes
and be like I'll come back to this it's
it's it's okay it's so good it's so good
oh God God forbid we have all this [ __ ]
going on [ __ ] but no like it's so good
that it's like I I would not be able to
rest until I've continued watching
everything all right I mean it reminds
me of like early Game of Thrones We're
not gonna bring up this like can of
worms again right because
you didn't like early game you didn't
actually like good television that was
right you want [ __ ] it's it's it's it's
not that I don't okay I'm I'm gonna I'm
gonna bring this back up because I
remember I remember when Charles I'm
remember when Charlie was talking about
remember when he filmed the Charlie
episode he was like yeah I think like I
think like anime fans are pretty chill I
I think like film and TV fans are the
most toxic I was like ah I don't know
Charlie and then the [ __ ] episode
came out your take was so colossally
[ __ ] that I think everyone across the
board I don't even believe it I think
even people have never watched Game of
Thrones late I don't it's probably not
because I I look back at it I'm like
yeah I still I still agree with that
take because
it's because I didn't even okay here's
the here's the thing that confuses me
right here's the thing that confused me
I didn't even say that I I didn't even
say that I thought the first like half
Game of Thrones was better I just said I
preferred like the latter half of Game
of Thrones
there's a big [ __ ] diff okay okay
here's the thing
here's the thing okay go on explain
yourself I I will explain I will explain
myself okay I will explain myself I will
okay you're wrong okay so
uh I I think I mentioned this briefly in
a recent video I did but to me I value
stuff more like even if it's not
perfectly executed versus something that
might be highly claimed highly like very
very well executed that doesn't appeal
to me the reason the reason the latter
half of the Game of Thrones appealed to
me more than the early seasons of Game
of Thrones is in the early season Game
of Thrones great writing great
television okay but a lot of the stories
in Game of Thrones it was it wasn't like
five stories that are in Connected there
were like five separate stories so you
had the stories going with he had the
story with King's Landing the story with
Daenerys the story up in the wall
they're all really interesting stories
but they were all like their own kind of
individual stories in that sense and
what really interests me and what I love
seeing in what I love what I value and
what I love seeing is different elements
kind of like colliding in together so I
the thing I was waiting for in Game of
Thrones was to see these separate
entities these separate elements yeah
start colliding in together right and
then I still really really appreciated
the first four seasons of Game of
Thrones but when I've really really
start to get interested was you know uh
when Tyrion you know got shipped off to
Daenerys and I was like oh okay we're
seeing one character interact with
another character and then and then
elements Stark lines together and I
found that interesting and then you know
when I'm not gonna say season eight was
[ __ ] even close to me it was [ __ ]
okay when I say I prefer the latter
Seasons everything but season eight
season eight was [ __ ] yeah but like
season six and season seven I would say
they were they were a bit messy they
weren't well executed but they had
elements in them that I was waiting to
see for Game of Thrones this entire time
and just I I you know I can say that I
think the first four seasons were better
written but I can also say that even
though the latter seasons were more
metally executed had worse writing I
still I still see them as very very
entertaining television I still see them
I I think the reason people clown on
their late season so far so much is
because the first four seasons were so
[ __ ] good right yeah I mean so I'll
explain this without spoiling anything
and without you know going into too much
detail
um so the the you mentioned that like
they're all individual stories about
because the way it works Jerry is that
Game of Thrones will like be like here's
here's this scene where it's happening
at this location right and then another
scene in this location across the other
side of the country yeah and so it was
like God said it was building up to that
stuff was kind of gradually they were
kind of intertwining yeah and the first
three or four seasons there's stuff
happening and it tended to be quite
insular but there would be stuff that
happened quite a lot that would have
Rippling effects and I think the reason
why people like Game of Thrones so much
was that if any other Rider had had
written it it you know they it would
have
that when something happened in Game of
Thrones it was very like Slow Burn and
minute how it would Ripple but but
everything was into consideration if
somebody did or said something it would
have such a like really subtle effect or
every single like
yeah there was every single interaction
was so carefully considered yeah and I I
what really pissed off a lot of fans is
that one after the like season four it
kind of went to like okay these
characters just fundamentally just
changed like they just weren't writing
them the same as they were in the first
four seasons they weren't as intelligent
they started becoming more dumbed down
and also like travel became really
really fast as well so before in in Game
of Thrones I was traveling it would
genuinely take like maybe a season for
someone to travel right yeah or maybe a
few episodes
um and even then that might have been
too fast right like yeah I it was it was
all very subtle and very very realistic
it was meant to be like a serious
political drama where if you said
something and pissed off the wrong
person maybe in a season no two when
they when they go to somewhere else it
might have a ramification right yeah
every single thing was taken into
consideration all the counter
interactions were so perfect and then in
season five six seven eight it started
getting dumber and dumber and dumber and
like you mentioned like like there's a
character called Tyrion who was
typically quite smart and he just
becomes a [ __ ] stupid idiot in like
the past in the past like three seasons
at the end he just becomes dumb and and
is com the complete different character
to what he was written as originally so
people were pissed off because all the
characters got stupider and and none of
the like the ramifications were
happening it was just kind of like duh
big fight happened now and then
characters would suddenly have a lot
more plot armor than before and some of
the characters shooting down to the
lowest common denominator yeah because
one of the one of the things that Game
of Thrones did really well if you
haven't seen it is that when a character
would be in a fight they had written it
so well that you genuinely didn't know
who was gonna live and die yeah like
there was the plot armor was never
transparent I was never like apparent
sorry and you never felt like someone
could 100 live just because they were
this character yeah because the first
season sets it up that hey you know
characters are gonna die right away like
characters that you thought were the
main person or characters you thought
were very important to the story will
die yeah and towards the end it was like
this is the main character they will not
die yeah and no matter what situation we
put them in you can be pretty sure that
then there's not going to be
consequences and I think so it became
less like a a very very thought out
written TV show and kind of went to a
triple A Hollywood movie where we know
the main guy wins at the end yeah and I
think that was the problem like it went
down to like a regular formula that
everyone's yeah because even the writers
they said like publicly they were like
hey we want to make it so that some like
a football player who doesn't care about
fantasy can enjoy right and it was like
okay so yeah the writers just fully
admit that they dumbed it down yeah like
it just went dumb and yes those moments
that everyone was waiting for these big
fights and these big like collidings of
Worlds and all of these like kind of
rivalries coming out to play would have
been [ __ ] amazing if they were
written correctly oh no but they won but
obviously they were still it was still
as a fan who would probably watched Five
Seasons a part of you is still like oh
this is still kind of cool like you're
still like this the battles you're like
it's kind of hard and do you think that
happened because like the fan base got
more like I guess more generalized
because there's a few reasons so there's
a few reasons one is that they kind of
ran out of books to uh adapt yeah and
the books only went to about halfway you
could see such a big shift in the
writing from when they just ran out of
materials because uh I believe Joe R
Martin gave him like gave them the
Baseline of where the story yeah
but not like the nuances right yeah yeah
so I you know I I look at this late
season of Game of Thrones and I'm like
where these character ends up where
these characters end up make sense story
wise how they ended up there does not
make sense at all yeah you know a lot of
things were also mentioned and then
never brought up again yeah and also
they had requested I can't remember it
was supposed to be 10 seasons yeah and
for some reason it ended up being eight
yeah and so they rushed to feel you feel
that it's eight like but even with how
bad the writing was I I don't know if it
even would have still been good by the
end of it because it was so [ __ ]
yeah I mean I see I I don't I don't
think it was [ __ ] I think like okay but
if season it was hot garbage dude see
okay season that hot Garbage I'd say
season five it was yeah five five to
seven it's like a solid eight eight hour
turn seven was not good seven was not
good I don't like seven either I think I
think five is where you start to see the
cracks six is where it starts to get
worrying seven is where you're like oh
oh it's ruined and then eight is like oh
God oh God oh God it was so bad it was
really it was horrible could you imagine
that you've been with something for like
12 10 years of your life and then right
at the end they're like let's just [ __ ]
it all up let's make it [ __ ] and and I
thought I genuinely thought I was like
I'm over Game of Thrones I'm done I
don't care about this world anymore yeah
I'm I I do not yeah and then House of
dragons started it's so good and it made
me realize just how amazing like the
world of Game of Thrones is and I'm sure
people watching this don't give a [ __ ]
about Game of Thrones but generally the
world is so interesting I think it's one
of if not my favorite like fantasy world
it is it is I think the way it's been
built up is so realistic and you could
see some kind of parallels to the real
world and how seriously politics is
right no that's that's that's that's the
reason I got invested in the world of
Game of Thrones and that's the reason I
really still enjoyed the later Seasons
it's because you got to see different
aspects of this world collide together
and I just you know when you've when
you've watched enough things I've you
just come to realize you I know all my
tastes are you know I can still
appreciate good television but I know
what core elements appeal to me and
there are more core elements that appeal
to me in the later seasons of Game of
Thrones even if it was more messily
executed and I've just come to value
that more and I feel like there are a
lot of shows out there there are a lot
of I mean I [ __ ] like I thought of
course I would say this I [ __ ] like
isekai right but like but like I'm sorry
but like there are enough games enough
shows enough movies that are out there
that might not be perfectly executed
might not have the best execution but I
still on a personal enjoyment level
still really really like even more so
than maybe some critically you can't
clip critically Acclaim shows in that
same genre yeah because if to me like if
I were to use like an anime analogy for
me someone who's never seen Game of
Thrones it sounded like it started off
as like you know the the political
fantasy and you know very nuanced type
of heavily detailed world of something
like Kingdom yeah and then went to
something like fairy tale yeah
yeah it went it went where it's like
nothing makes sense but the main guy
wins and there's lots of big fights it's
just like it's insane when you when you
watch uh oh you read about how you know
very subtle things have happened in the
show you're like this is insane like the
level of detail yeah yeah and and
thought that's put into how all of these
worlds and characters interact is just
insane yeah
um it's Kingdom to fairy tale yeah it's
it's genuinely Game of Thrones showing
it yeah from the sounds of it yeah it's
probably why I enjoy it
but hopefully he finishes the books
I mean like I would still have preferred
the later Seasons with all these
elements compliance we with the same
nuances of like that would be in the
perfect world right but I still go I
still got what I wanted and I was
entertained thoroughly
um and you know I was just I was just
thinking is this really hotter than my
bread take you know yes yes
I'm just like oh all I was trying to say
is I have my own [ __ ] yeah you have
to understand right I think the Game of
Thrones ending in final season was like
one of the biggest betrayals of like TV
to the fan base more than Game of
Thrones it's very on brand yeah right
like it's literally on brand like can
you think of a TV show that burned its
fan base harder like I I genuinely can't
like I can't think of anything that is
up to was that hyped it was that big of
a deal that [ __ ] up that bad
like no no fairy tale no they [ __ ]
still love it
I'm plenty of shows go to [ __ ] but you
okay not on the scale that Game of
Thrones did it right this was like a you
know everything it did literally it was
like a day and night difference it was
like it went from everybody loves this
[ __ ] to now everyone in the western
world was talking about yeah yeah it was
Non-Stop and it also just goes to show
clearly how impactful that was that when
yeah they were able to green light so
many spin-offs that you know even though
everyone was like Game of Thrones
[ __ ] sucks that when they brought out
this new prequel that they shoveled
shoved way too much [ __ ] money into
that the moment the first episode
dropped everyone was like hype
it's so good everyone get back on this
it's actually hype it's actually good
and to be fair the first season was
[ __ ] amazing they only have like one
book um to work off of and it's finished
the story is completely done yeah but
they're gonna make like three or four
seasons from just one book
um and it's insane like even the George
RR Martin has said that some of the
characters in the TV show are portrayed
better in the TV show than in his mind
on the book oh wow he's like he uh
there's a character in particular that
was done really well
and he said like I wish I could go back
and redo those pages now I wish I could
take them out because it's so much
better on TV it's so so so so so good
please if you got burnt on Game of
Thrones give House of dragon a shot it's
so worth your time it's so good yeah
it's probably one of my favorite like
first seasons of TV in a long time wow
all right yeah I mean I I will finish it
so so good it's I I will I will reserve
my opinion I'm sure everyone's raring to
hear my opinion on House of dragons it
comes back later
I'm gonna kill you gone if they added
some more armor then I would have liked
it yeah I mean it's it's good like like
I said I'm I I always I with certain TV
shows I can appreciate I can always
appreciate good TV but sometimes I just
sometimes I'm just waiting for something
to interest me and I don't always know
what that is sometimes it's a certain
like plot element sometimes it's like
the cinematography or the way it's like
filmed or something like that yeah it's
I get it there are just some there's
some shows is where it's just like I
can't explain why I like this like I
know it sucks yeah well I just like I
don't know love Island you know like
that as an example
Love is Blind for example right like I
[ __ ] love that show I know that
show's trash it's just it's [ __ ]
reality TV right but and I can't explain
why it's good I just can't stop watching
it you know it's like it's like and he
is a guy show right it's like you can't
explain why it's good you probably know
it sucks but you're probably gonna keep
watching it has has that has there ever
been a show that you you know is like
flawed not not like it's not like
something that's like obviously trashy
but but you know it's like flawed not
executed perfectly but there's not been
another show like it and you're just
like you know what I'm I'ma look over it
you know I still enjoy it because like
for me I I recently just made a video
about it it was recreaters which is it's
got like such a unique idea in terms of
just like you know when I watch a video
I watched it by the way oh you watched
it yeah yeah I completely forgot about
it yeah because
because one thing I've noticed is that
you eat like that that kind of show you
either think it's just okay but everyone
who likes that show really really really
[ __ ] likes that show yeah yeah
um and I'm one of those people and
that's just because it was like it
wasn't like the best executed way just
had such an interesting unique idea that
you don't see anywhere else that you're
just like okay you know maybe I don't
really give a [ __ ] I don't really give a
[ __ ] I've really enjoyed it was
definitely like it was definitely like a
polarizing show when it was airing
because I remember it's like you either
like [ __ ] love this show or you're
like yeah oh yeah I do remember when it
is because I I remember the conversation
surrounding it yeah and I watched it and
I think I only watched four or five
episodes and I stopped because yeah too
much talking yeah exactly
um yeah and it was at the pace bogged
down a lot yeah yeah because like I I
think that's why a lot of you know
that's why the indie game scene has like
grown so much whereas it's like it's
these game developers who instead of
trying to compete against the AAA games
doing like the you know as much as I
love God of War it does very much go
with the AAA game formula at least it
deserves the triple a title it deserves
the Triple A game title and like a lot
of other AAA games but I feel like the
indie game scene has grown so much
because you have a lot of these
developers who are just like I really
like this one idea and I don't see any
other game doing just this one idea of
doing it really really well huh
is that name a better jumping all right
I'll wait Mario
I'm not as good yeah my man's invented I
guess I guess James games like jumping
where you take this really really cool
idea yeah focus on nothing else but that
core idea is he gonna appeal to the
masses no but the people who like it
they really really really like it you
know and I feel like one of the best
games that came out you know in the past
five ten years A lot of them have been
Indie Games yeah yeah when you talk
about like like undertale when that was
out right that was insane that was
everywhere yeah I still gotta play
undertale it's so good all memes aside
megalovania and sex memes
I don't give a [ __ ] megalovania is
probably one of the best [ __ ] music
in a video game I've heard in a long
time I know the memes exist but every
time I hear I'm like I play that [ __ ] at
the gym I'm just like this is
true hype for the gym it gets me pumped
up I'm like I gotta defeat Sans
God what are you gonna ask will I still
enjoy it yes despite the facts that I've
been exposed to so much of it I think so
yeah I think like that yeah no matter
how you get exposed to it I think the
ultimately the experience you have with
it is definitely going to be different
from him I feel it's a very personal
game where like you know because again I
feel the story is very dependent on how
you perceive it and how you want to go
about it because it has the multiple
endings and stuff yeah yeah yeah so it's
like I feel it's it's a really good game
to just kind of like sit down and play
with yourself and really just like get
fully immersed in it yeah um because I
feel like I don't know I tried streaming
it once and I'm like I couldn't really
get into it because there's just like
too many outside Falls just like yeah I
think I would say it's a game to just
like play on your own terms yeah
um also the music is and story is
amazing because Toby Fox yeah the story
is really good I mean I care about it so
that's saying something that's that's
tough to get me to be like Oh I'm sad is
it
all to say that I think Toby Fox is a
better musician than he's a Storyteller
uh I don't know I I I'm not sure what
other music he's done he did some music
for Pokemon he did just a lot of pieces
for the new people he's very talented
either way he's super tough this is like
this is like no matter what which one
he's better at he's still better than me
and everything
talking about like very Niche games that
would you know only appeal to you
there's been a game series that I've
been thinking about getting into it's
it's a very very Niche jrpg series oh
God
something like this you would [ __ ]
hate Connor
um but I don't I don't even know if I
have the heart to commit to this right
what uh have you ever heard of like the
trails of atlia series or Trails yes I
have heard about it okay so I've never
played it so so I've been like so for
the past like two months I've been
trying to like psych myself up to see if
it's if it's worth getting into so so
let me that's so familiar okay let me
break let me break this down to you okay
so I I I hear like bits and pieces of
this of this game series right and then
the first thing I search up is how to
get into the trails series on YouTube
and I swear to God one of the top videos
the the video was how do how to how to
get into the trail series one hour and
50 minutes long
bro and I was like oh oh boy oh boy and
I was I was like surely surely there's a
shorter video than one hour 15 minutes
the shortest video I could find was a 20
minute explanation that's the shortest
that's the shortest so this is this is
like setting up the stage for the type
of game series that this this game
series is okay yes yes I have I have
seen this before yeah that's the kiseki
series yeah yeah so I've never gone into
them though because I've heard it's like
it's got such a high Benchmark to get
into it yes yes so so before before even
deciding okay so I'll explain to you Joe
because I've done I've I've done
research just to see if I want to get
into this game okay I haven't even just
played the game I've watched like I've
watched like these full videos just to
see if I wanted to play it right
uh because it's a game series that has
ran on for about 15 years or something
yeah right it's got 11 games
and what what I find really really
interesting and why I'm like oh should I
commit to this game is that every game
is following on from one giant
overarching story so it's it's a game
where you have it's according you know
according to a lot of the people that
play it's got one of the best examples
of World building in gaming period it's
like the one piece of games I'm sure I
could [ __ ] make a big block yeah yeah
yeah so it's it's like it takes place in
this one all 11 games takes place in
this one kind of like big universe right
and each game it kind it's it's similar
to I guess something like Game of
Thrones right where you know you have
individual story arcs in different
countries different areas of this world
that slowly interconnect and mingle and
start like characters from previous
games start to like have a proper big
effect on characters on story arcs in
like a different country and then slowly
start to mingle in and collide together
and I'm like [ __ ] that that's that
sounds like that sounds that sounds like
season six again
that sounds like everything I want in a
[ __ ] game that sounds like everything
I want in a video game series 11 games
it sounds like and it's still ongoing
God I'm never gonna [ __ ] see you all
right it kind of sounds like the Dune of
video games you know kind of like
different planets and like the planets
interact with one another yeah it's all
based in this one yeah and like one of
the biggest things I've heard is that
it's not like it's not like different
games Cameo into each other it's not
like one person cameos into this this
different game it's like prop games have
a proper impact on what happens stressed
out yeah like the story the story arcs
of one game have a proper impact to what
happens in a different country different
country story arc and I'm like holy [ __ ]
you know gone I'm about to finish the
Pokemon game
if you're committed
it's honestly like I I remember I
remember like reading something about it
I was like this this sounds something
like I could be interested in and the
more I researched more I'm like [ __ ]
this this seems like a game that I would
really enjoy but yeah I can't 11 games
11 games maybe I'll just watch one other
video just uh
let me watch one more hour and 30 minute
video so the thing is is Imagine This
RPG where every single the NPCs that you
meet you can actually play them in the
later years
you have like 30 plus characters that
just that just means every character
matters in every character oh yes oh
that sounds like okay I've seen this
first game trails in the sky yeah uh I I
I think I had a friend who had this uh
on like Windows I think
um and he was like yeah because I
specifically remember I remember the bar
of Entry being so high for this game
series because my friend was like he was
playing this game and I'm like oh that's
a really cool game what is it and he's
like you shouldn't know
you don't need to you don't want to know
should every character matter
I disagree I don't think every character
should matter
means if it's if it's
if they'll be ones who impact that story
more but I think it's okay to have NPCs
and characters that don't really do much
but I think it's a cool concept where
you know you can be NPCs and someone
else's story at the same time that
doesn't mean you can't have your own
story which it sounds like it's it's see
because I've read the Dune books and
it's exactly the same okay it's like
it's like the NPCs in this first book
are now the main characters in this
ladder book that makes sense I like the
Dune world I just think that when you
just the way you're describing it to me
it sounds awful um because at least Dune
is like hey here's a nice there's a nice
like sandwich have a little bite of this
sandwich right and then it's [ __ ]
ginormous and you don't realize how big
the sandwich is before you get a bite
and you're like well that tastes pretty
good actually
does this not sound like that too no
this sounds like that's only because you
know how many that's only because people
know how many games are in this season I
know how much Dune there is but also
like I I just was like oh if I can watch
the movie it seems good you know that's
a palatable way to to well then I'll do
this I would be like oh play this first
game so if you good yeah and if it's
good you had to watch an hour video just
just to play the game we're talking
about that's no that's not accessible
let me see how long it takes on average
to beat the first game this is too much
for me it was it was mostly just I think
I was just tell me you won't you don't
want 100 other games but you're like
I'll get into this 500 hour game
collection yes yes
I I okay like I said if I know that
there's a payoff if I know that there is
that can not be a payoff worth if
there's something that I really like and
really appeals to me I will be willing
to grind through Heaven and Hell to
[ __ ] get to that according to how
long to beat main story 40 hours easy
easy for one game
but if you care about the NPCs yeah yeah
it says completionist is 65 which is not
too bad but you [ __ ] mean not too bad
that's a full-time job for a week dude
completionist for like Final Fantasy 10
is like 120 hours I think that I've done
that before I think game devs and like
on G's like because you know I used to I
used to care about gamer school why I
don't know why
like Pac-Man and Shameless School Xbox
games oh yeah oh you told me because I
know that sometimes you like play
against someone in card right and you
want to [ __ ] talk them and you open up
their profile like oh it's gonna go 200
games yeah they'd open up my profile
it'd be like 90 000 game of school and
they'd be like oh [ __ ] I want to mess
with this guy well no I want to be the
same way if I interact with another jrpg
player they'll be like oh you're a jrpg
fan what have you played and then I'll
be like finish the entire Trail
seriously be like
oh my God
I like the quantifiable number and so I
used to just play games a lot and I
would just play some games that were bad
but there is a quantifiable number 11
games is it like a score a score that
you can show to other people and people
see right oh so that's what I enjoyed
but I would play games I didn't even
like just to get the stupid score I
would like buy games that were rated
easy online to get 1 000 like full game
of score because you'd only get 1 000
gamer score in every game and a DLC you
could add more you were gaming the games
I don't know what happened there was
like three years where I was obsessed
with this thing where I was like I just
care about getting this number go up I
get that so I would play like I bought
like lost the game you know lost the TV
series I bought that game because it was
like five bucks just to get a thousand
games because it was really quick to get
a thousand Gamers score and then you
know I I also then some of my friends
won a game of school and I was like well
I'll do it for you if you give me 200
Microsoft points I'll get you I'll give
you like 5 000 game of score and I would
just do it in a day because I had like
loads of games hustling game of schools
yeah I would I would if someone won a
game of score because I I again I wanted
I wanted points so I would kind of do I
would figure out ways through gaming I
was like how can I use my talent gaming
to get Microsoft
gaming so what are your what are your
talents I I'm really good game really
good and addicted to this gaming thing
can I get money from it or can I get
somewhere to get more games from it so I
would like mess I would like my friends
would want some people to do it and then
I would message people I'm like hey if
you want game of score do it no I said A
Sketch choose [ __ ] but I actually did it
like if they gave me the points I would
log in their account and I would just
play these games hey kid you wouldn't
gave a score but then if they wanted me
to do specific games they'd be like
Oscar that's that's a toffee dude all
right I'm gonna need more
and then and then I realized oh you can
just take the internet out of your Xbox
get a USB and like download a file and
it will just [ __ ] do it for you and I
was like and then I felt really dumb
that I was spending like a day or two
doing this oh my god um but yeah no I
would I was obsessed with it I would buy
games for it I would do achievements
that was stupidly hard spend hours like
days like Halo I would spend days
getting all the Halo achievements
because I mean that makes sense and and
then and then I would get infuriated
when I would buy a game that I thought
was good and they would have impossible
achievements in it and you know which
ones were always the worst jrpgs always
always the worst 100 completion yeah
Final Fantasy these stupid [ __ ] games
would be like get every single item in
the game it's like yeah you are
psychopaths like you you willingly chose
this achievement [ __ ] me I I did that
for the new 7R though yeah that's stupid
I I think the reason I just never 100
games was because I did it once with
Tails and then I was like never again
never 100 of the tails game yeah I'm
sorry I loved it that to me that's like
200 hours you know you can remember back
in the day when you only had like that
one game to play until next Christmas
sure sure like to me for me that was
tails that was when I had time and I was
like I don't know what to do I have no
other videos I think that like having
like like having to go somewhere for
like one day it was like made me a busy
man and then yeah I could spend the rest
of the days playing video games I was
like damn that one day thing that
crashing I'm like bro I'll kill Stacy
games now I'm like I will kill for one
hour yeah sure I literally do anything
for an hour yeah it's really weird for
me with the video games because I could
never play for like one or two hour
stints a noise if I if I have a video
game I like I need to play for at least
like four hours oh man I've been able to
enjoy a game for like 20 minutes and
then just do something else as hype
right it takes me 20 minutes just to get
like invested into like the game that's
why OverWatch and games like that are
pretty fun because you can just do like
two games 30 minutes go back to whatever
you're doing pretty nice so I just play
module
like you can get a quick game out of it
you want to reset your brain you want to
like kind of just take your mind off
what the work is for like 20 30 minutes
yeah I mean maybe you don't want to take
it then like one game turns into like
two games I'm pretty good
at that point I'm just like and then at
that point I'm just like well I'm five
games
bro like going on tour with Connor off
entire hold up no no that's different
that is different because uh our entire
schedule revolved around whether Conrad
started the game of Kia [ __ ] tiona we
would be like yo Conor rehearsals in
five minutes Connor's like but but I
just started I just started the game I
just started a game of DFT guys I never
played near our rehearsal time that's a
[ __ ] lie no no and most I would push
it back five minutes that's that's not
true I would play a lot of TFT because
we didn't really have anything to do a
lot of the time yeah so I was like oh
just game but in normal work it's like I
will pretty much I will work from like
nine to ten Non-Stop and then I'll have
to take a break at some point and play
some games because always I'll get my
brain will be like wait 9am to 10 AM 10
p.m okay I have to say I'm like I'll
work yeah
I don't know I normally have to like
stream and then I'm like all right I
have to do real work
now I'm gonna answer emails too much fun
I gotta I gotta feel like I didn't have
fun yeah exactly speak for yourself
stream is like people pure gamer right
here stream is definitely worked for me
yeah streams work for me I don't
actually like it it's fun
it's really a game for me I was thinking
like should I stream god of war and I
was just like no I just because I I
wanted to just be like immersed in the
game and just say like damn this show is
really good think of the five Subs yeah
yeah yeah the only way that we'll be
able to get through the trail series is
if we stream till last year like
realistically so that's the thing right
if there's a game that is too long it
makes no sense to play it off stream
because you know it's a big time sink so
you should play but then there's no
point doing it on stream either because
then viewers will just fall off yeah
true maybe yeah maybe because I tried to
do that with Yakuza 7 and like after 11
streams I don't care people just don't
care so I'm like [ __ ] it I'll just
finish this game because it depends on
the game because like you know Pokemon
it makes sense right yeah because it's
like you can just tune in whenever you
immediately know what the [ __ ]
happening there's no concrete story you
can just immediately be like oh you're
trying to catch some Pokemon cool I'll
join in but like you know 10 streams
into Yakuza 7 where it's like the story
is pretty much fleshed out at that point
it's like oh I don't know what the [ __ ]
is happening therefore I'm not gonna
stay I think people need to enough
people need to have played a game or has
to have like a really hardcore fan but
it's like you know Final Fantasy online
or you know yenshin even you know
invention streamer yeah because that's
why you're such an easy Grace you can
come through that streamer yeah the
streamer that plays that game yeah yeah
such an investment and that you know
anyone who would want to watch would
also be interested in that game yeah
yeah but yeah honestly it's it's also
games especially as well so you know
who's going to be the world's first
Trail stream
there's got to be one out there right no
one cares don't do that do not do that
because like Trails I'm like this is
this I see some light trails and I'm
just like this will never ever ever be
popular but holy [ __ ] it like it just
speaks to me there's five Japanese dudes
somewhere in the world who are like the
hot most hardcore Trails fans who are
just like please give it to me the more
I get into streaming the more I want to
do non-game streams like the more I want
to do like I want to go fishing yeah
that's that's the OG game yeah can I eat
today like I feel like I want to play
the analog like I'm more interested in
streaming like classical stupid [ __ ]
like like fishing or like outdoor stuff
that I think is like kind of games or
like you know games before games yeah
you know activities
yeah yeah yeah I don't know why yeah
let's discover yeah
real life stuff is great but what are
they gonna patch this mechanic man I
can't believe fishing the time the fish
is too long like the fish the fish is
like too much RNG man they're like this
this is just like gotcha but like
[ __ ] yeah so I've done I've actually
done fishing a few times in Japan now
all right I did the fishing with mailing
in the ocean yeah uh that was that was
[ __ ] hard mode fishing that was just
hard much harder than uh Lake fishing
lake fishing and River fishing is nice I
like that that's like the perfect battle
Yeah you you get fishes uh at a good
Pace yeah you know and it's much more
relaxing as well yeah yeah you can sit
down on the boat you're like [ __ ] oh
God am I gonna get a fish I don't know
for like four hours and then you don't
get anything
it's just [ __ ] yeah and then you kind of
like you want to go to the toilet you
have to go in this shitty little boat
like I just I everything about it I just
want to piss off the edge of the boat
dude yeah yeah I went on this uh fishing
thing with Maylene and it was it was fun
it was just too long it was like it was
like eight hours on like on the water
yeah I had done it three hours man yeah
because I went like Lake fishing again
after when like sea fishing would mail
in I just realized damn Lake fishing is
just it it's just so much more chill and
I'm like
the friends who made along the way yeah
and I go see fishing I was like oh this
is why fishing is a job you know because
it's it's hard it's hard work
I'm wet I'm soaking and you know I we'd
be I'd be there for hours right and I
would I would be staring at these like
old Japanese men who were like nuts at
it and I was literally copying
everything they were doing I thought
they had the straps I wasn't doing it
because like I I would I swear to God I
would like literally one for one mimic
exactly what he was doing and I could
not get a fish to save my life I got
like two fish total this these dudes bro
it was like that's like that's like
being like you know oh I'm gonna play
Dark Souls and watch this Dark Souls no
I just do exactly what they do I
recognized it like I'm definitely not
these dudes have been doing it their
whole life yeah and the thing that I
liked about like in sea fishing was
really [ __ ] hot because the technique
matters a lot yes um
whereas in a lake you're like
blop yeah wait and then that's it yeah
it's good it's fun you can chat you can
chill out you want to drink a beer
you've got to like pull it you're
pulling it yeah
these dudes are nuts dude these Japanese
men I mean it's in it's in the blood man
it is a generation man throws it in two
seconds got like five on one hook I'm
like what the [ __ ] is happening man and
he's just like at a pity he's like
here's a fish genuinely out of pity he's
like bro I've caught too many I'm like
hey you want one yeah sea fishing was
just frustrating for me because I'm like
what the [ __ ] am I doing wrong I
actually have no idea what I'm doing
insane yeah million's been a ton and
million wasn't getting anything don't
you do this often can you be getting
more fish yeah because I did the exactly
the same way where there were some
Japanese men like catching like
literally a bucket full of fish yeah I
like mimic everything they're doing the
right way nothing yeah I throw it in
nothing throw it in nothing because they
had the the [ __ ] like cracked uh
fishing pole that's what I'm guessing
yeah yeah yeah I had the the school the
school uh Sports Hall pop fishing pole
they're like yeah we got a pole we put a
line on the end yeah yeah I don't know
you gotta stick with a piece of strings
they felt so bad for us that when we
docked and went back in because you pay
like 15 bucks to go out and fish yeah
and you're allowed to catch as many fish
as you want so there's some corn they
give you free fish as well yeah the dude
was like
that's it yeah hold on we caught like a
ton the other day he owns a bag
I guess he just felt bad yeah yeah with
the same thing but it's also as well I
feel them doing that is like backhanded
because like the game ring you was like
no I could do better I mean it's not
that I was trying to just clarify I'm
not frustrated because I didn't get
enough fish I'm frustrated because I I
hated the whole the vibe of it and how
long you were dead like a rainbow yeah
and you know you you dock and then you
drive out on the boat for like an hour
yeah and you're just the sun because it
was in like August so the sun is
destroying you as well and you're like
this this [ __ ] sucks because unlike
unlike Lake fishing sea fishing is a
commitment you can't just be like oh
just just talk somewhere let's just
chill out you know somewhere go yeah no
just just go can't pull the camping
chairs and put the beer yeah yeah
exactly I can't do that it's a
commitment and unfortunately the sea is
the sea you know and if if if you need a
place to rest you still like it's still
rocking a lot yeah because it's the sea
and it's a lot more intense than Lake
fishing I was actually like sweating at
a point doing uh doing sea fishing
because it's like it's a workout it's
it's so much more intense because you're
constantly having to do something it's
not a passive activity it's an active
activity
um but you get you get like bigger fish
for it you know that's that's the
trade-off sometimes
if you can catch it yeah a little fish
are fine too they taste good yeah yeah
yeah they're fine good so I want the
five stars though man I'm waiting for my
first five star man you have a catching
big fish is way harder than getting a
little fish like a lot lot more yeah
yeah I know but then we're not capable
of that guy well we gotta stay in our
lane 20 years too late but I I just want
to know what that feels like you know I
wanna I wanna know I want to know yeah
yeah
us me Immortals we haven't been fishing
for like 20 years I don't get to we
don't get to do that no I don't know
there's other sports I really want to do
as well more I want to do more Sports
essentially as well I'm the same yeah
trying to do more kayaking I want to do
a lot more of that I wanna I wanna surf
as well I went surfing with Felix the
other day yeah
intense like it is it's a good workout
it's a incredible workout but I it just
made me realize how unfit I actually am
oh
no I knew but like it just it just
reaffirmed my suspicions right because
it's like I was probably out there for
what maybe two hours yeah and I was just
[ __ ] destroyed like because it's it's
the part that it's it's the paddling out
that just takes all the energy no and
maybe it's because like I heard I saw
some people you know saying like oh it's
because you were in like cold Waters and
that just saps the energy out of you
more than like summer warm Waters and
stuff like that but I think that's only
up to a certain extent like you need to
be at a certain level of Fitness guys
but that's actually you guys are on
copium yeah that's copium it's like yeah
you know but um no it's really fun like
even if like I didn't I probably maybe
caught one wave and I didn't even stand
up for it obviously but like even just
like catching that one wave while on
your stomach it does seem hard it's it's
hard it is very hard but it's super
[ __ ] fun and like yeah I definitely
want to go back
um yeah yeah so I remember trying
surfing for the first time as well it
was so much [ __ ] fun but like you
said you spend most of your end energy
not actually doing surfing it's actually
like paddling out it's like getting out
because you have to like go against the
waves yeah you don't realize how much
energy that takes Until you realize you
spend all this energy to maybe like to
get one chance to catch like a wave
right and if you don't catch it then you
then you [ __ ] up and you gotta paddle
out all over again you know yeah so it's
it's a lot it's a lot of energy it's a
lot of waiting as well it's a lot of
waiting especially if like the waves are
kind of mediocre like it was when we
went yeah yeah um it's just like a lot
of like oh is it hit no oh is it no and
you're just sitting in the water for
maybe 30 minutes yeah freezing your ass
off right because you're not moving at
all and then the one burst of energy you
have to use to catch that wave that you
might not even actually catch yeah you
just get way close to the Sean you go
well [ __ ] now I gotta paddle back out
again yeah and use up all this energy
not serving it's like with skiing or
snowboarding it's [ __ ] easy because
uh like the [ __ ] ski lift does all
the work for you yeah it's like it's
like if you went skiing except the ski
lift wasn't lurking working and you had
to walk
well I guess I gotta go all up all the
way again where's the ski let's just
surfing yeah
just like pick me up drop me off and put
me in the ocean but I'll show you I I
don't know why am I stupid I'm like
what's I wonder what outdoor sports that
are cool that would work for streaming
like okay surfing doesn't work there's
water if there's you are getting wet or
submerged it doesn't work anything like
that done kayaking could work but if you
go too far out to the ocean there's no
signal yeah yeah so you gotta kayak
around somewhere maybe in a river
snowboarding maybe see okay I thought
about this I thought skiing or
snowboarding could could work and
technically it's possible but I wondered
would it look [ __ ] on camera because
it's literally just White
uh it's just white and then you're going
fast down so there's like opportunities
to talk and stuff but I'm like I don't
know if it could be interesting you
would also need I guess maybe like a
wide lens to you know kind of capture
you and the rest of the thing because
this is like the the camera I have is
very wide okay it might work yeah yeah
but I guess also like is there like but
like some mountains I know don't have a
great signal either yeah it depends it
depends depends on the mountain depends
I don't know I just want to do more
weird outdoor stuff no that's right I
just I want to do more Sports Outdoors
but it's hard to convince anyone I'm
down okay okay good good yeah I'll hold
you to that yeah lean mountain climber
because I went because I went surfing
with Felix and then the week after we
went to driving range
as [ __ ] it's like oh I actually kind of
missed doing this during the pandemic
because I just got so [ __ ] lazy
because we couldn't go outside didn't
couldn't move our body because no one
else was outside yeah all the places
were closed but now everything else is
open and people are like yeah I kind of
want to get back into shape or like I
kind of want to move my body I'm like
well let's [ __ ] go
I like trips that are like focused
around doing an activity right where you
like maybe go for two days to like kayak
somewhere yeah yeah or to surf or
something I like that because I feel
like okay well it's a it's a holiday but
also you get to relax you do some
exercise it's like you've got to get
some endorphins
a lot of those sports that require
they're like expensive or you need
equipment or someone is good to teach
you around yeah yeah a lot of the a lot
of the sports require knowledge entry
points it's like it's yeah it's the
point of entry right where yeah that's
part of the reason I never went skiing
or snowboarding just because you need
someone who can help you yeah the
barrier Adventure was so high yeah no
one in my family ever skied or
snowboarded when I was younger so I was
just like well I guess uh I guess I'm
never going yes I'm never going yeah
that's true actually it for sure helps
yeah um I I wondered there's definitely
a scene for very odd extreme sports I
know there's like a scene for
um actually hunting in German man really
yeah you can you can you can uh like
with live animals or just like the clay
pigeons live animals oh really you can
do it for some reason I stumbled across
something and I was reading about it
it's quite interesting it seemed like
it's you have to it's a very long
process to get a gun in Japan yeah it is
um but it can be done and you can hunt
in Japan didn't know there was a scene
for hunting in Japan didn't think so
either yeah I thought everything was
[ __ ] protected no no no there's
certain animals that you can hunt oh
certain Birds but know that fun fact
Japan often has a scene for very like
Niche Sports oh yeah but you need to I
wouldn't even know how you'd even begin
to get into stuff like that here that's
the problem is like a lot of like I feel
Japan is the one country where there are
so many small cool little niches that
you can get into whether it's like
physical or just like hobby based or
something like that but like it's either
the point of entry is so high or the
community surrounding it is so small and
hidden or gatekeeping yeah that it's
just like kind of hard to be like can I
join yeah you know without them being
like oh you want to be a train or taco
name five trains it's like it's like uh
I don't know it's like [ __ ] off you know
it's like there's always that because
like because I wanted to do a video on
like kind of the weird like you know
like the the small little niche otaku
spheres like the train or tacos but the
problem is a lot of those people just
don't want to be public about it and
don't want to talk about it because they
don't want it to be like a mainstream
thing you know they want to keep it in
their small Niche I know that some of
the train attacks is that game is that
gatekeepy I don't know maybe it's it it
is geek yeah it totally is
if you ever watched the James May Series
in Japan oh yes he talked to some train
attackers and he was like I need a TV
products so why do you like trains and
they were like and he was just saying so
he's like all right
all right that's cool I actually saw a
gun store in Japan
like live guns yeah like a gun store I
walked past a gun store and I was like
oh where was it shibia no I remember I
walked past it I can only think of the
one in [ __ ] yeah
I was thinking as well
I I remember walking past it and being
like that's a lot of guns wow and I was
like that like real guns not like real
real guns real guns definitely real guns
that was definitely real okay I remember
seeing because I saw the some of the
stuff outside and I was like oh yeah
that's real that's real [ __ ] because
airsoft guns they'll have what's the
word they call it they have um the
they'll have like Survival game written
over it so yeah yeah yeah I doubt real
guns would have Survival Games a
survival game yeah that's really cool
they call it hardcore yeah they call
airshop Survival game in Japan yeah
which makes it sound way more hype than
Airsoft see Airsoft is a bad name I feel
like it makes it sound way wimpier than
it actually is yeah oh how soft is it
survival games Survival the game
oh [ __ ] all right I'm down I I feel like
Airsoft done itself dirty with that name
yeah yeah
I mean when when gas guns or something I
mean when you're in America with like
real guns you need you need something to
like you know you're just like I I wanna
I wanna shoot some guns but I don't want
to shoot something that could kill
something maybe maybe so maybe it's
pretty much hurt someone yes and there's
a bunch of airsoft bars in Japan as well
so much fun yeah yeah it was very funny
uh get going like uh
I have one shotgun this is so much fun
oh yeah I heard you've been to one
before as well right I went to one in
Sendai yeah yeah there's if you go to
Japan maybe just Google Airsoft bars
they're pretty fun you can drink and
then shoot Garland yeah yeah it's pretty
fun there's much in Tokyo isn't there
yeah yeah yeah that's I mean if you look
for very Niche odd bars there's so many
of them yeah just go on Tick Tock at
this point right that's that's the
places you find them yeah I didn't know
that I wanted it I needed to shoot a
grenade launcher in my life but I now I
did yeah I know I knew that that was so
much fun shooting a grenade launcher
then being like I'll have a sip of my
drink now yeah that was fun that was
very fun I mean talking about things
that appeal to Niche tastes it's like
Japan is the country of that oh no no
100 yeah not just in video games but in
every game everything in real life real
life real life game the non-video games
oh yeah I just remember they we went to
that fishing restaurant I hate that
place so much oh yes oh so there's this
restaurant you can go to in Japan and
it's a very big touristy Place yeah um
there's a few of them in Japan
um yeah where you can fish your own fish
right yeah yeah okay so yes you fish you
fish the the fish and then you eat it
right and and they'll ask you how you
how you want it prepared but these fish
are like dead so you have to like stab
them with the hook you don't yeah you
don't catch them you kind of have to
shimmy the hook into the part of their
body and then drag them out yeah it's
very like oh this doesn't feel right
yeah and it's like really oh it's gross
and also like they don't even use the
fish that you even fish up right like
they have like a different fish prepared
I don't know I don't know if that's a
rumor but I mean I I would hope so just
from seeing how half dead some of these
fish I'm like I don't know if I'm I
don't know if they're good to eat like
food is mad as well that's all right
that's fine I mean it's it's fine just
it's mid it's just like fine the sushi
was fine it's fine I was just like damn
it it's acceptable I wish I ate other
Sushi like what just anything else
anything else
yeah Sushi chains in Japan even like the
100 yen ones pretty [ __ ] weird
they're pretty decent they do the track
as long as it's not don't get the sushi
from the conveyor belt just order it
from the tablet yeah get it fresh yeah I
mean I I noticed now that it's even if I
go to a conveyor Bel sushi place it's
rare that it's full of sushi anymore
most of the time people just order from
the tablets nowadays yeah yeah and it's
because it's like why would I want the
sushi that's been going around for 40
minutes yeah yeah Sushi they just made
yeah exactly like that sounds much
better I'll do that thank you yeah even
like the cheapest Sushi change you can
find in Japan is like better than some
of the expensive Sushi though like
worldwide so that's why I in a sense I
prefer going to like cheap conveyor belt
sushis and some of like the more higher
end sushi places because it's rare that
I'm ever full in like the higher end
sushi places you know yeah yeah but is
that what it is yeah
it's rather than that I'm ever full and
I just feel guilty like ordering more
from the chef to be like you didn't feed
me enough give me more and then you
order like one or two more pieces I'm
like [ __ ] how do I tell I don't think
they mind I don't think they're mine no
they don't mind because they're still
getting the money for yeah
I mean he you know he'll eat like the
majority of like the fish and stuff like
that but you know some of the weirder
ones like like he doesn't like not
though or like the sperm sacks or [ __ ]
yeah oh like I don't even think he likes
uni if I I'm not too sure but like he
obviously like but if it's just like oh
regular white fish or or whatever salmon
finally though yeah it's obviously my
parents want to come visit Japan and I'm
like damn I don't know if they're gonna
what kind of sushi they like yeah have
you you thought about this I mean I've
had to think about this actually do you
think your parents are gonna like sushi
um okay so I've not I've thought about
this for both
Shinji like yeah should I take them to I
don't know because you know
um I have my parents coming and then I
also have Sydney's parents coming as
well
um and I'm like uh how can I describe
Sydney's parents like okay so my parents
are very very white British yeah
it's like how do I get them to eat
anything that isn't cooked yeah like
Sydney's parents are like the most
American parents you could like ever
ever imagine like Sydney's dad is like
the epitome of like an American Dad
right
uh he's like I have white and blue yeah
yeah yeah he's like every American Dad
you've seen in every sitcom won every
[ __ ] movie and everything like that
and I'm like how do I I it's it's just
like I I know hi Russell if you're
listening to this by the way it's it's
like I know it's like the type of person
you take to a sushi place and he's
asking where the fork is you know yeah
this is my dad I don't think I've ever
seen my dad use chopsticks maybe he does
I don't know actually yeah can you
pronounce these Chopsticks pretty sure
my mum can this is my day I didn't find
it I'll find out I would I would say
maybe start your parents off on you know
something like salmon right the salmon
yeah I I will see what they like I'll
take them to a sushiro yeah and I'll be
like all right we're gonna try one of
everything yeah if you don't like it
don't if you don't like it I'll eat it
I'll eat it and then we'll see how it
goes
yeah I mean I mean I think Sushi's Sushi
should be fine
um I'm thinking but there are also
people who are like very weird about
eating raw meat right yeah well it's not
like I'm gonna be like hey eat this by
the way it's raw horse
I mean see she's not the one I'm worried
about it's some of the other things that
they can find in Japan which might be
having like a little bit harder I think
a sushi is like I want them to try that
and other stuff you can get sushi in
like yeah
that's good
um and that excuse me was fine um
because I don't want to take them to an
omicase place and then the the sushi
chef has been doing for 50 years like
please enjoy like what the [ __ ] is this
here you go I don't want it here you go
I don't want it you seen the I've seen
videos of like someone stabbing the
sushi with the fork and they're putting
in like their salad and then eating it
yeah I've seen videos of these from
because of tourist office coming in oh
my God yeah I I wonder why what other
dishes do you want them to try
what is like you know well actually it
depends when are they coming
in April I don't know I'll figure it out
I think in January
I just holy [ __ ] maybe like maybe like a
nabe of some kind
[Music]
although the raw egg might throw them
off a bit yeah I'm Gonna Make Them Eat
Sukiyaki I'm gonna be like you gotta
make you gotta make them yeah yeah I I
think I can get away with raw egg you
know I think they'll complain about it
and I think it's weird but as soon as
they try it hopefully hopefully
hopefully I mean I was I feel like the
if you're younger it's really easier
right because you're more open to trying
yeah right obviously if you're older
you've been eating the same things your
whole life and you're like why sure I've
survived without raw egg I don't think I
want to try it it's just like it's the
Japanese Cuisine is just so vastly
different from like Western Cuisine yeah
and you know now the world's become more
let's say like globalized and everything
like that so people our age I think I
feel like we've got we've had more of a
chance to try all these different types
of Cuisines stuff like that yeah but
when you get to a parent's age you know
it's it was it's it was a lot harder to
try different Cuisines back then let's
say in fact it's like surprised me so
much just how much Choice there is now
nowadays uh UK UK went from like nothing
to like good now exactly you know I go
to like most major cities and they have
like proper Cuisines of like every type
whereas but I remember before you go to
a Chinese restaurant and there was only
like one type of Chinese restaurant you
know which was just basically orange
chicken yeah orange chicken kung pao
chicken like and now like you go to the
UK and there's like so many different
types of Chinese restaurant which is how
it should be it's like Szechuan food
it's like Chinese hot pot
um and I'm just like wow this Choice
wasn't there when I was growing up in
England God knows what the choice was
like when my parents were you know it
might also be because maybe back in our
parents generation there wasn't enough
like uh understanding or knowledge on
the subtle differences of a lot of like
food like that so maybe the maybe they
existed like maybe you know like
Szechuan food and hot pot and like you
know traditional Chinese food did exist
but but it was probably all just labeled
under Chinese food yeah right and it's
probably just like oh it's it's from
China so it must be just Chinese food
and you didn't Pro probably there wasn't
enough information out there to be like
oh this is a different type of Chinese
food yeah well this is a different type
of Indian food yeah well you know
anything like that right it's like you
know I'm sure like back in our parents
day there was just like there's Asian
food and that's it it's Asian food and
there is non-asian I remember when I was
growing up in in Brighton at least when
when we wanted like when we wanted
Chinese or Japanese food they were both
under the same restaurant yeah it was it
wasn't Chinese or Japanese it was
Chinese and Japanese yeah it was like an
Asian fusion right it was like the
opposite in terms of like flavors yeah
you know Chinese food is often quite
heavy maybe oily yeah whereas Japanese
food it's very light not so many spices
meanwhile Korean food is full of spices
I mean I remember I remember when it's
growing well I remember when growing up
Korean food just wasn't a thing no no no
I was like you you had zero choice of
Korean cuisine and nobody knew about it
either it was either Chinese or Japanese
Indian you know yeah and it's just weird
now seeing how many different Cuisines
are like coming up there like Vietnamese
cuisine is like coming up as well
whereas before I was just like oh I
guess I I I've had Thai food that's you
know that's that's just all the stuff
before it was like let's get up that
Asian restaurant that has Sushi Pad Thai
yeah like so that's everything I could
be wrong but I Jordan the Thai
government and I think it might still
does like they they sponsor a lot of
people opening up Thai restaurants
abroad
um if they do that's five hit because
they wanted Thai food to be like really
well known right yeah
um I'm pretty sure they did that I
wouldn't be surprised because I think if
you look at all the foreign foods from
like southeast Asia like it's only like
Thai food is the big one like it's been
pushed the most yeah I think it's
because the government was like hey we
need to get our food out there I mean it
makes sense when pretty much everyone in
my parents and dad's side who emigrated
out of Thailand started a restaurant
business so yeah I'm pretty sure there's
like a text out like there's something
some kind of program maybe
there is not a single Thai person who
has come out from outside Thailand who
didn't at one point in analyze yeah I'm
just I'm just thinking I'm just like
we've got a fact checking okay all right
what do you think 2002
oh 2002. yeah thousands of restaurants
around the world
because they realize like Hey how do we
get our name on the map let's make bomb
ass food the people are gonna be like no
I want Chinese food yeah yeah and you
think about it more right you know of
the country you know about it like yeah
I don't know a lot about some other
Southeast Asian countries because the
food isn't really like pushed that's
true yeah and it's kind of it's very
neat and food is very intrinsically
linked to the culture too oh yeah yeah
that's right like dude I mean I swear
half of the hype around Italy is how God
damn good their food is yeah you know
but no one ever thinks to stop about
their government we don't talk about the
Italian government the Italian politics
Italian politics are kind of whack but
their food you know you think about it
yeah everyone every single family member
that has emigrated out of Thailand uh
and I've started a [ __ ] big family by
the way or in my parents generation
started a restaurant business almost for
a restaurant business
um yeah that that was that was like in
the 1980s though is there is there a
particular Cuisine that you want more
people in the wall to like know about or
try that you think is like personal
progress in the white guy
Subway sandwiches
damn I I really want to just try more
Southeast Asian food but worldwide
everyone should know that's hard to say
um I still think to this day Greek food
is underrated no
you don't like Greek food no no Greek
Greek food Greek food is so hit or miss
really and dude it's all down to what's
the [ __ ] sauce they put on everything
um Suzuki yeah if that [ __ ] doesn't if
that if they didn't make that properly
the food none of the Food Works I mean
not making good Tzatziki at a Greek
restaurant is being like Oh we got
vinegar instead of soy sauce for your
sushi it's like you know it's like such
a staple that it's like if you [ __ ] up
at that point there's no going off I I
I've had them I've had some amazing
Greek food that I thought was so good
but so often so often Greek restaurants
outside of Greece are so [ __ ] it's like
whoever runs it just hates everyone
in the UK in the UK or I've been
anywhere else in Europe you know I've
gone to other places in like American
I've tried Greek food and it's like I
don't know what it is it's so hit or
miss really it's like Italian it's you
can normally rely on it to be decent at
least one or two items that you like and
there's always something and it's and to
be honest you you have to really [ __ ]
try to [ __ ] up Italian food yeah like
I'm not saying that it's easy to make
but like at least the base ingredients
are pretty readily available and the
recipes aren't too complicated and like
you have to really be have awful [ __ ]
maybe I just had a good because in
Australia we have a lot of Greek
immigrants maybe like I feel like that
I've been to like two or three Greek
restaurants in Sydney and they're all
[ __ ] bomb they were so good so good I
don't know if this is like anecdotal I
think I've had the worst service
consistently in Greek restaurants really
I think so I've had the best service I
feel like a really a dude I don't know
is that like there was a Greek
restaurant it's not there anymore that
was like near my house and like we would
go there because it was quite expensive
and it's expensive to eat out in
Australia right we would go there for
like if it's like a family member's
birthday or if it's like a New Year's
thing or something like that some kind
of Celebration and we went so often year
after year that like the head chef and
like most of the people who worked there
just knew who we were yeah and we got
some of the best [ __ ] service ever
like I've never seen my dad tip in
Australia except for at this Greek
restaurant every time my dad's like my
man yeah she could have gone there yeah
and it's not there anymore I don't know
maybe I need to try some restaurant more
restaurants let's see there's some
recommendations I mean I haven't been to
Greece so I I don't know if I've had
like other things that's nice yeah
everything was really cheap I remember
that I remember the food was quite good
yeah but that that's what makes me want
to go because I had such a good
experience at Greek restaurants in
Australia literally on the other side of
the [ __ ] planet from Greece that I'm
sure the fooding actual grease is just
as good if not better yeah I like the
food grease it's good yeah I feel like I
need to try more like Greek Foods uh I
think there's one thing that I feel like
I don't gel with Greek food and it's
just unfortunate that I just don't
really like Feta cheese you know I'm not
you're not only feta I don't really like
Feta a lot of people don't yeah and and
that's it is it is a strong taste it is
it's like a very very good though it is
a very very strong taste a bit too
strong for you like palettes you like
lamb though right yeah I like lamb okay
yeah good Greek lamb bro don't worry I'm
not Emily don't worry
yeah when I eat lime it tastes like
goat's cheese and I'm like what like
they I mean yes they come you know goat
cheese and and uh you know whatever it's
I'm like how the [ __ ] how the [ __ ] does
the mink taste like the goats I don't
trust someone who said Yuzu tastes like
lemon cleaner I don't like Yuzu that
much though I I but do you think it
tastes like lemon cleaning it's a very
strong taste I will admit I don't know
if it's I want to get Emily back on
because she's the only person I've met
that could like rival she's all of our
teams like put together like holy [ __ ]
every time she comes out every time she
like in private or on [ __ ] Twitter
every time like we talk about food
she'll say something [ __ ] outrageous
so I'm like I thought I had bad I'm just
like I'm sorry I don't I don't believe I
heard what you just said could you
repeat that family told me she didn't
like lamb and I was like
what what do you mean you don't like
lamb and so I I I'm like you know what
maybe you've just had really bad land
yes like in America I think they got
many good lamps all right I don't think
it's fresh I don't think it's good stuff
I was like whatever let's I'll take you
to somewhere that is rigid lamb and
Hokkaido it's really good [ __ ] that
place we went to oh you've been there
yeah the genius complex yeah and I was
like let's just try this it's a
different style you cook it on the grill
right yeah yeah that's so good you get
like veg on the side and it cooks and I
was like all right we'll try every cut
I'm gonna try a little bit of each one
because she was like I don't dislike
lamb I just don't think it's that good
yeah and I was like well let's try it
yeah and every single one she's like
there's like goat's cheese and I was
like
and then she's like I just I just think
beef is way better than this and I'm
like what
what it's like it's different foods
different occasions you know I I think I
don't know what it is does she not like
the gaminess of it maybe I think so
maybe yeah I I can't accept people don't
know
I understand if you don't like it for
the gaminess but not for the subtle
cheese flavor that it has which it
doesn't I don't know what she's on yeah
I don't know so yeah that was
frustrating but I like lamb a lot I
don't see him Welsh I love life yeah but
I feel like a lot of times in Wales they
didn't really cook it very well all
right yeah I will say it was always lamb
chops as well yeah I will say like
comparing like lamb to beef beef is like
a lot harder to [ __ ] up yeah I feel like
lamb if you don't cook it correctly of
the meat quality is not good there is a
there is like a real strong aftertaste
that can be very off-putting with land
but when you get good lamb [ __ ]
incredible whoa have you ever had
someone ask you
uh how would you like your pork cooked
no no someone was like do you want your
pork medium rare and I was like what
I was like
I'm like what do you what do you mean so
I went to um uh a katsu Place katsu is
uh breaded uh
pork and then like fried yeah um and
they were like do you want it rare or
medium rare or well done I was like what
it's like what do you what do you mean
it's tonkatsu yeah yeah I was like isn't
it deep fried how do you do what I was
like what do you mean I was very
confused and they were like the show
also it's pork you should not be yeah so
the chef was like we recommend it medium
rare and I was like okay I guess I'll
trust you because it's your pork and you
do this a lot yeah I'll get medium rare
and it was slightly pink very slightly
pink like like a little bit of pink in
the middle yeah but it was bomb it was
really [ __ ] good and I was like is it
safe yeah I assume so otherwise I don't
think they'd be open isn't red pork like
kind of bad yeah I don't know is it can
we google this well then this is also
the country that also does like raw
chicken like it was when I say it was
the one I posted on Twitter that picture
of the tattoo so like it was it was
clearly all white with just very dots of
pink in the middle so I assume they were
trying to cook it because often if
you've ever if you've ever come to Japan
and you have cheap katsu it's sometimes
it can be like fighting like it is
fighting a war you're like biting really
hard to kind of separate because the
chunks are normally quite big yeah so
you do want to it's normally at least a
two biter and sometimes it is pretty
hard to get through it and you're like
okay [ __ ] man maybe it makes sense that
it would be medium rare but it worked it
worked yeah it's a little bit pink it's
okay so that's probably why it was good
it was it was tasty highly recommend it
they have it was a chain I'm sure it's
gone but like I would also be a little
bit worried if the chef came up to me
and said how would you like it I was
just I was taking her back because I I
never had that before it was like a bog
standard cut like corner street uh katsu
place
I I I I ordered it and I was like oh
well you know what do you what do you
mean like I'd never heard of Chef ask me
that and I thought he was saying
something else because I thought I
thought I misunderstood yeah because I
was like what the [ __ ] do you mean
medium rare what no I didn't get beef
yeah but now is that it was good I
recommend it so if you ever get if you
ever get asked in Japan how do you want
your tonkat to and if the guy recommends
medium rare trust him he knows what he's
talking about so so bottom line with the
Emily thing she tried all those
beautiful cuts of meat right A lot of it
was Australian Cuts as well if I
remember and there was deer there as
well
she liked the deal yeah yeah and then
she was like ghost she's in it I think
she just liked I think people just like
beef sometimes and I think some people
associate like beef in the uh sorry meat
in the head as chicken or beef and then
pork is somewhere in the middle but I
think some people when they've only
really eaten chicken and beef a lot they
kind of only really think about those
too and they think there's the white
mean there's a red meat and so every
flavor of meat in their mind is like a
tree that starts from chicken or beef so
I think like some kind of I think
there's some kind of thing when you just
don't eat yeah I mean it's like a mental
thing right away you try something new
mental death and you're just like
what did she expect when she said to the
Welsh person I don't like lamb and I was
like what do you no that's not allowed
it's because you've had [ __ ] laughs yeah
[ __ ] lamb but now she's had good lamb
man apparently that didn't change I
didn't change your mind apparently at
the end of it she was like no she
doesn't tastes like goat cheese I'm like
what the [ __ ] is your palette what is
this [ __ ] every time someone's like
allergic to dark deathly allergic to
food now I'm gonna be like scalicious
[Music]
why why are we why do we just should
restart the game
what are they allergic to things why
does that happen do we know why
allergies happen yeah why would you
become allergic to [ __ ] skin issue
[Music]
I don't understand more is how is it
that your body is just like yeah so um
you're allergic to this this and this by
the way so don't ever have it in your
body and then 20 years later they're
like never mind I changed my mind is it
like you're good now is it like a like a
you know how like games when they ship
and there's bugs like that where like
it's like it's like a patch I feel like
there's got to be like some kind of bug
on the DNA strand well because like you
are you are allergic to this fruit that
is nowhere near where you are born and
no one in your ancestors have ever eaten
you're like what well because my my dad
how did that happen my dad was born with
a prawn allergy and then at the age of
life 20.
one day he was just like yeah and then I
could eat it my allergy just went away
I'm like how does that work yeah I don't
get it yeah some people who are allergic
to like everything you're like what went
wrong like what happened how did you
just get alerted to everything like what
how does well you developed an allergy
to I developed analogy to catch and and
some reason adults yeah skill left dude
yeah
imagine not being able to pet every dog
I would end it I would be like I would
end it now I would just start again
I'm I'm smacking differently on the
skill tree minus intelligence not
allergic to dogs
what's the point my happiness meter it
cannot cannot be full I've maxed out my
dog petting skill tree yeah that's just
[ __ ] man I need to tell him he's a good
boy
that's so [ __ ] stupid that's [ __ ]
up but he just thinks it's something
else it's like oh God are you dying it's
just a like a chicken wing
is anyone allergic to chicken
uh maybe you know we should do for trash
taste we should we should take one of
those allergy tests and then we should
report our results are we allergic to
any weird specific things oh yeah
because they can give you like a test
where they prick you with like every two
thousand different yeah yeah yeah yeah
and they're like all right look you're
allergic to octopus fangs
you're good
I used to be uh I used to get hay fever
and then I didn't and then I was just
like I don't know what happened I just
woke up one day and then I just did wait
wait so you had hay fever in the UK but
not here right no I had hay fever in the
UK yeah and then when I turned like 18
or something I just stopped having hay
fever really yeah I don't get it in the
UK or anything anymore your body just
decided to be a giga chat
sneezing now I told my body to get good
and it did so it's like it's like when I
hear about people who like they they ate
they they ignored their lactose
intolerance so much that they just
somehow stopped being lactose intolerant
I'm like you sacrificed so much no but
that but that's an actual thing that can
happen it's like because like you can
also develop it if you don't have enough
Dairy rice but also you can do the same
thing with like cats for example yeah if
you live with the same cat that you
started off as being allergic to yeah
and you just let your immune system just
fight that [ __ ] for like I think it's
like a couple of weeks on average yeah
it is true because that's what happened
to Chris oh okay yeah Chris was allergic
to cats but then when Chris and Charles
suddenly be together she has a cat yeah
and then he had to live with this cat
for you know have him anyways after a
while he's like I'm not allergic to this
particular cat your body just learns to
process that particular cat's allergens
or whatever the [ __ ] it is whatever I
try to keep it a secret he had a cat and
there's the the cat hair constantly kept
appearing on him
that was so funny like really Chris
rookie mistake yeah but so like that
that is like one way that you can just
get over so it's really interesting in
the case with Chris it's that he's not
allergic to this one particular cat that
he lives with yeah but every other cat
he's still allergic to huh and it's like
your body just being like yeah you're
good with this all these other ones
though no you're still [ __ ] being
allergic to these fruits and whatever
the [ __ ] any of this stuff yeah I could
I could live with that
but I couldn't be lactose intolerant man
I a world without cheese is one I don't
want to be in aren't we old technically
a little bit lactose intolerant no we
are I don't know if you would like toast
intolerant you would just take the L and
just like fight I would I would fight
this as the man who has food poisoning
every [ __ ] week you you you were just
like lactose
[Applause]
kids who are allergic to peanut butter
are like [ __ ] it they eat like the
peanut butter uh the like Reese's
complimenters stabbed himself with the
Epic man it's like I think I would be
that kid I would be like [ __ ] it
like sitting profusely on the toilet
seeing like the cheese risotto thing
they do where they they cook like they
put the McDonald's cheese they like half
the cheese I'm like all right all right
good enough load the bidet ready I'm
going in
like I have some friends who live here
who are like full on lactose intolerant
like can't eat any Shades at all some
days when I'm out eating with them Asian
right they have yeah sometimes I'm just
out eating with them and they're just
like [ __ ] it like that looks too good
I'm just gonna take the hair so [ __ ]
Jesus so [ __ ] good it's gonna be
shitty for a straw for the next two days
God I love that's the one thing I can
agree on with French people yeah
[ __ ] great
I love cheese sir I I would cry
profusely if I was like her satara yeah
I would too I just don't do it I I don't
think I could continue I don't think so
I'm just glad I don't have a food
allergy you know yeah you know when you
go to a restaurant and you're like do
you have any food allergies no yeah
it's like David can you get chat theme
sauce
play it
[Music]
because I love food so much and I love
like so many variations of food that
like it would just be such like an
immediate hindrance to just like yeah
actually get explorative with food I
feel yeah and it sucks it must [ __ ]
suck but like you know I got some
friends with some peanut allergies where
it's like you have to go into a
restaurant as a [ __ ] battle because
you have to profusely make sure that
they know like hey I cannot have
anything with peanuts yeah peanuts you
cannot breathe near peanuts and walk
near me like they're and sometimes they
take it seriously and sometimes they
don't yeah yeah I mean it's unfortunate
um because I remember when I when during
my wedding you know obviously I had to
get everyone's dietary requirements oh
yeah and then everyone was just like
fine fine fine fine fine and then you
know had one person have to like send me
a [ __ ] shopping list
this is what you have to live with a
friend in the UK who's uh allergic to
Sesame yeah um but they're Asian
yeah of course of course they use sesame
oil a lot of the times to cook yeah yeah
just forget yeah they'll get sick a lot
well boys that's it I hope you guys
enjoyed this episode of trash taste
thank you very much it was nice to have
a food conversation and not be shouting
at each other's throat for once how rare
is that that we bring up because we
weren't talking about what we lied we
talked about what what a [ __ ]
we talked about what other people can't
eat
stuff that I I like and the others don't
it's not that's not my problem shout out
to those who are allergic to Foods sorry
about the skill issue but let's go there
the run's dead man restart it
hey look at all these patrons though
yeah that you know that there's one
thing these patrons are not allergic to
and that's trash taste yes hopefully
hopefully maybe one day they'll develop
analogy for us blink twice if your mum
took your credit card away but uh hey if
you want to support the show then go to
our patient on patreon.com trash days
also follow us on Twitter send us your
memes on the subreddit and if you had a
face listen to us on Spotify and uh buy
our new merch yes that's that's a thing
yes
your chat by the merch got it link to
the description go check it out hell
yeah we'll see you guys next week bye
[Music]